PRESIDENT TRUMP'S HOME ON
MONDAY.
LET'S BRING EVERYBODY BACK WITH
US HERE.
AND I WANT TO START WITH ELIE.
FIRST, THE LEGAL ELEMENT OF
THIS.
THIS APPLICATION, IT SOUNDS LIKE
A BIG DEAL COMING FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
IS THIS UNPRECEDENTED?
HOW RARE IS IT TO REQUEST THAT
THIS BE MADE PUBLIC?
>> THIS IS A REMARKABLE AND
UNUSUAL MOVE, VICTOR.
WE ESSENTIALLY SAW MERRICK
GARLAND CALL DONALD TRUMP'S
BLUFF.
HERE'S WHAT I MEAN BY THAT -- IN
THE WAKE OF THIS SEARCH WARRANT,
DONALD TRUMP HAS TWO DOCUMENTS,
HE AND HIS LAWYERS.
ONE IS THE SEARCH WARRANT ITSELF
WITH WHATEVER ATTACHMENTS, THE
OTHER IS THIS INVENTORY OR THIS
RECEIPT.
NOW THOSE DOCUMENTS ARE GOING TO
HAVE IMPORTANT INFORMATION ABOUT
THE SEARCH.
THESE ARE THE DOCUMENTS PEOPLE
HAVE SAID IF DRUM DONALD TRUMP
WANTS TO MAKE AN ISSUE HE SHOULD
RELEASE THEM.
MERRICK GARLAND SAID THE DOJ ARE
GOING TO RELEASE THEM.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE JUDGE TO
UNSEAL DOCUMENTS, MEANING MAKING
THEM AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC.
DOJ POLICY IS THEY WILL ONLY
SPEAK ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE ON
THE RECORD WITH THE COURT.
SO ESSENTIALLY MERRICK GARLAND
SAID, OKAY, DONALD TRUMP, YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO RELEASE THEM, WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT, WE'RE GOING TO
PUT THOSE DOCUMENTS IN FRONT OF
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WILL AND WILL
NOT BE IN THOSE DOCUMENTS.
THE WARRANT TYPICALLY WILL LIST
LOGISTICAL INFORMATION, PLACE TO
BE SEARCHED, USUALLY A GENERAL
DESCRIPTION OF ITEMS TO BE
SEARCHED FOR, THE NAME OF THE
JUDGE, A DEADLINE BY WHICH DOJ
HAS TO EXECUTE THE SEARCH.
BUT IT ALSO SOMETIMES HAS WHAT
WE CALL AN ATTACHMENT.
THAT ATTACHMENT TYPICALLY WILL
LIST THE STATUTES, THE LAWS THAT
DOJ BELIEVES IT HAS PROBABLE
CAUSE TO BELIEVE WERE VIOLATED.
SO THAT'S GOING TO BE THE FIRST
THING I LOOK FOR.
I'M GOING TO LOOK RIGHT AT THAT
ATTACHMENT AND SAY DO THEY LIST
THE STATUTES, THAT'S GOING TO
TELL US WHAT LAWS COULD BE AT
PLAY HERE.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE SECOND
DOCUMENT, THE INVENTORY OR THE
RECEIPT, THAT IS WHAT IT SOUNDS
LIKE.
IT'S A LISTING, THE FBI SAYS
HERE ARE THE ITEMS THAT WE
REMOVED FROM MAR-A-LAGO.
AGAIN, DEGREES OF SPECIFICITY
AND GENERALITY TEND TO VARY.
I DO NOT EXPECT THAT TO HAVE A
PIECE OF PAPER BY PIECE OF PAPER
BREAKDOWN.
IT THEY TOOK THOUSANDS OF PAGES.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
IS LISTINGS LIKE X NUMBER OF
BOXES, IF THEY TOOK ELECTRONIC
DOCUMENTS, IF THEY TOOK ANY
LAPTOPS, CELL PHONES, THAT KIND
OF THING.
ONE LAST THING.
THE DOCUMENT THAT WE STILL WILL
NOT SEE IS THE BIG ONE -- THE
MOST DETAILED DOCUMENT HERE IS
THE AFFIDAVIT.
THAT IS THE DOCUMENT WHICH
TYPICALLY CAN BE 20, 40, 100
PAGES WHERE PROSECUTORS LAY OUT
CHAPTER AND VERSE HERE'S ALL OF
OUR PROOF THAT GIVES US PROBABLE
CAUSE.
DONALD TRUMP DOES NOT HAVE.
THAT MERRICK GARLAND IS NOT
MOVING TO UNSEAL THAT.
THE OTHER TWO DOCUMENTS THAT
DONALD TRUMP HAS, MERRICK
GARLAND SAID I'M GOING TO SHOW
THEM NOW.
>> THAT AFFIDAVIT IS CRUCIAL AND
CENTRAL TO THE INVESTIGATION.
YOU WOULD EXPECT THAT THAT WOULD
BE RELEASED AT THIS POINT.
>> NO.
TYPICALLY THAT ONLY GETS
RELEASED IF AND WHEN THERE'S A
CHARGE.
IF SOMEBODY GETS SEARCHED AND
INDICTED, THEN THEY WILL BE
BEGIN A COPY OF THAT AFFIDAVIT.
AGAIN, THIS IS THE VERY LONG,
DETAILED DOCUMENT.
SO THAT THAT PERSON CAN THEN
CHALLENGE IT IN COURT.
TYPICALLY THE DEFENDANT OR THE
PERSON WHO'S BEEN SEARCHED WILL
ASK THE JUDGE TO THROW OUT
WHATEVER WAS FOUND BECAUSE
THEY'LL ARGUE THAT THE AFFIDAVIT
WAS INSUFFICIENT, DID NOT
ESTABLISH PROBABLE CAUSE.
SO THAT'S THE LONGEST, MOST
SPECIFIC, MOST DETAILED
DOCUMENT.
WE ARE STILL NOT GOING TO SEE
THAT, BUT WE ARE GOING TO SEE IF
GARLAND'S MOTION IS GRANTED,
WHICH I SUSPECT IT WILL BE, BY
THE JUDGE.
THEN WE WILL SEE THE W